what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos where you can come to
catch up on all the fun stuff that you
missed in the past week the links are in
the description recommendations go in
the comments
now usually we post these every Sunday
but we're a bit late this week because
we've been working on a bunch of other
videos and livestreams as you may know
we've been getting a huge amount of
support lately a huge amount of
subscribers thank you guys so much and
we want to do our best to make sure that
we're making as much good content for
you as possible and without further ado
let's get to the videos now definitely
the biggest story in the anime YouTube
community last week was all the drama
between two big youtubers for never
world and double for anime if you're not
aware these guys actually use to be
friends for quite a while before having
a falling out and essentially becoming
enemies and rivals in recent weeks
double for anime main several videos in
which he called us for another world on
a really personal level and remember
these guys used to be friends so they do
know each other personally last week for
another world finally responded with a
long again very personal video in which
she basically tries to counteract all
the stuff the double frenemies been
saying calling double for anime obsessed
telling him to leave him alone and all
this kind of stuff now I won't repeat
all the allegations because I don't know
what's true and what isn't I don't know
these guys but it's just been a lot of
drama so many people are talking about
it
scarce mentioned this on his channel so
yeah a lot of drama in the anime YouTube
community right now if you are
interested in this kind of thing I left
the links to both for never worlds video
and double for animes video in the
description last week glass reflection
uploaded his top 5 most anticipated
anime of winter 2017 in this video he
actually mentions that he wanted to do a
top 10 most anticipated list but he just
couldn't find 10 anime coming out this
season to be excited about as always
this is a really good list and two of
the animes that he mentioned little
witch academia and blue exorcist season
2 are the two anime that I am most
looking forward to this season so we'll
be watching those and I'll be updating
you guys on what I think another hot
topic in the anime world this week were
to crunchyroll anime Awards and I think
you can still vote on them until today
so if you want to check
if you want to vote on these awards
click the link in the description
personally I feel like the choices that
they give us are limited they're a bit
mainstream they're the kind of anime
that have been the most popular most
profitable rather than necessarily the
best quality ones so I don't know let me
know what you guys think in the comments
also we're going to be talking about the
drama in the anime community and also
the crunchyroll anime Awards in the next
episode of rant cafe which is going to
be live streamed on Thursday and 5:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time and we hope
you can join us along with our usual
friends we're actually going to have a
special guest this week black Critic
guys so definitely looking forward to
that and I hope to see you there as
always geekdom one-on-one has been on
top of his game as far as Dragon Ball
super goes and this week he uploaded a
review of the first dubbed version of
Dragon Ball super if you're a draggable
super fan definitely check out this
video and check out geekdom one-on-ones
channel an immense piano actually posted
a new video this week and it was a piano
cover of the first guilty crown ending
departures now this guy doesn't upload
that often maybe once a month once every
two months but when he does it's always
amazing it's such beautiful sound he
does such a great job and the views and
the likes that he gets speak for
themselves definitely check this out and
my favorite a MV this week was a blue
exorcist season 2 and V called all goes
to hell by youtuber Slayer AMV the music
use for this pan V really fits the show
well it was almost like an alternate
opening it fits that well I really
enjoyed it it was a great anvi
experience so be sure to give it a watch
and that's it for this week guys it
wasn't the busiest week you know first
week of the year everyone's still
getting back into their groove so other
than all the drama it was pretty quiet
if you do like these types of videos be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]